almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it we sadly
have to now have another sad
conversation we're start today's show at
the start is kind of a bummer but we're
gonna get some interesting things if you
bear with me we have to have a really
serious conversation about the growing
reality that the conspiracy theorists
are to a great degree winning right now
surrounding coronavirus now I want to be
really careful here this includes
coronavirus related conspiracy theories
but I'm also talking about conspiracy
theories that are being floated now to
distract from the administration's
failed handling of the virus so I'm
going to talk about both things and I
should be clear that when I say the
conspiracy theorists are winning I don't
mean most people believe the
conspiracies that's not what I mean but
there's an asymmetric priority here when
I say the conspiracy theorists are
winning what I mean is enough people are
either falling for the conspiracy
theories or reporting endlessly on the
conspiracy theories such that it is
wreaking havoc on the overall
dissemination of real information and
distracting from a focus on what matters
and that's why when this pond-scum
nonsense starts to spread they don't
need to get 51% of the population to
believe it they don't even need to get
20% of the population to believe it they
only need to do enough to wreak havoc in
the media and distract from the real
scandals really good piece in the
Atlantic by Jeffrey Goldberg which
actually goes into this and it goes
further and it says the impact of these
conspiracy theories winning is not just
on coronavirus but it's actually a
bigger challenge to enlightenment values
and to reality itself which we're going
to dig into there's also a piece and Vox
bye Shawn Ilyn which talks about sort of
the media's handling component and how
Trump uses the media to spread his
conspiratorial disinformation
specifically to distract from his
failings and we're going to talk about
that as well so first of all let's start
with Jeffrey Goldberg's piece in the
Atlantic and in that piece Jeffrey
Goldberg says Trump does not defend our
democracy from the ruinous consequences
of conspiracy thinking instead he
embraces such thinking a conspiracy
theory birtherism was his pathway to
power and in office he warns of the
threat of the deep state with the
ferocity of a qyn on disciple he has
even begun to question the official
coronavirus death toll which he sees as
evidence of a dark plot against him how
is he different from Alex Jones from the
conspiracy manufacturers of Russia and
the Middle East he lives in the White
House that is one main difference this
improbable question how did a person
with a weakness for conspiratorial
thinking achieve the presidency might be
among the most consequential of the
coming election which is not merely a
political contest but a referendum on
enlightenment values and unreality
itself nonsense is nonsense except when
it kills and conspiracy thinking
especially when advanced by the
President of the United States is an
existential threat and so when you think
of all the ways in which Trump supports
this new conspiracism there are many so
yeah as Goldberg points out the big
foray into politics for Trump was
birtherism against Barack Obama this
idea that Barack Obama may not have been
born in the United States may not be may
not qualify for the presidency because
of the birthplace of his parents but his
entire trade politics were also based
around these sort of go too far ideas
about China and it went simply from
being about currency and intellectual
property theft into climate changes of
hoax perpetrated by the Chinese we see
it front and center on
virus everything from Trump pushing
chloroquine is the cure what do you have
to lose from from very very early on -
it will just go away - the entire thing
that we've seen recently from Donald
Trump about just ignoring the fact that
there are people dying every single day
from this and of course with
conspiracies when there's a grain of
truth as there almost always is it helps
the conspiracy to grab a foothold we've
talked about this before the virus did
originate in China it just didn't come
from a lab it wasn't man-made in a bio
weapon Trump says it will go away well I
mean of course at some point it will
either kill everybody who's not immune
and then you've got herd immunity and
everyone who died has already died like
eventually it'll go away or we'll get a
vaccine or whatever the case may be
eventually it will go away that doesn't
mean that we just open up the economy
and do nothing and then Trump says well
some governors are being heavy-handed
that becomes armed protests by the same
people who think Bill Gates is involved
in some nefarious way to fund a vaccine
that will lead to a dystopian population
control nightmare that Bill Gates will
be in charge of and again just enough
people fall for this stuff that it takes
attention away from what matters and
from what's real keeping people safe
understanding when Trump is lying to us
minimizing damage to the economy in a
responsible way working together to get
past the lockdown phase and of course
just enough people fall for this stuff
that it starts to get media attention
and that's how they win they don't need
to be proven right they merely need to
justify their existence by getting just
enough attention and where we are seeing
it now front and center is with this
Obama Gate stuff I'm I don't plan on
covering Obama gate very much I'm gonna
do a clip or two here or there for the
purposes of debunking what's being said
but this is how Trump controls the media
Shawn illing for Vox writes Trump has
been able to essentially win merely by
turning the last week of right wing
media and even some centrist and
standard corporate media into
adjudications and debates about Obama
Gate any minute that is spent talking
about Obama gay
is a minute that they are distracting
their viewers from the mounting death
toll the failed response the fact that
South Korea and Taiwan got it under
control right away and we did not we
still have inadequate testing levels and
it's a tactic that Steve ban and I don't
know that Steve Bannon invented it
certainly he probably did not but he
uses it and it's called zone flooding
flood the zone with this stuff and force
the media to cover it you don't need to
convince a huge portion of the public
you just need to get coverage and get
people arguing on one side of Obama gate
or on the other side of Obama gate and
the media have really not adapted to be
able to handle this as Sean Sean Ealing
says the media aren't gatekeeping the BS
stories and to some degree media are
allowing more and more discussion of
Obama gate because it's ratings that's
number one
to some degree media want more and more
discussion of Obama gate because if they
don't talk about it it'll trigger a
round of BS attacks against them look at
how bias they are Fox is covering Obama
gate fake new CNN and the Washington
Post won't cover it so part of it is
they don't want to be seen they're
scared of being accused of suppressing
the story altogether and the mere
discussion causes what we call the
illusory truth effect even if most media
outlets are bringing it up to debunk it
exposure to the claims alone will get
some people believing them even if you
do what you believe is the responsible
thing you only bring up Obama Kate Obama
gate to debunk it as the bogus
conspiracy theory that it is you are
exposing more people to the claim and
more people may end end up believing the
conspiracy theory so at least for now
I'm not going to participate in the
Obama gate stuff we're going to talk
about it only at an absolute minimum and
we will talk about it when there is you
know irrelevant implosion by the right
related to it our audience also is not a
general audience it's people already
following this stuff but they win when
they get enough of the population
talking about this stuff even if they're
not chained
changing minds and the real impact is
that large swaths of the country
reopening in the middle of a pandemic
are doing so partially because of these
conspiracy theories about everything
from Bill Gates and government tyranny
and heavy-handed this and that Obama
gate distraction all of this stuff is
playing a role in getting policy to be
what they want rather than what public
health dictates let me know what you
think I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and
we'll have a few types of follow-up on
this coming up later today